the sec
and the acc intend to go forward the big
10 of the pac-12 standing down
in the middle was the big 12. and bob
bolesby the commissioner of the
conference made it clear
on wednesday that they intend to go
forward it's up to all of us to deliver
a safe medically sounded structured
academic and athletic environment
for accomplishing the outcome of getting
the season in
a schedule was released they start
september
26 they're going to do three tests per
week
for the student athletes which is better
than some of the stuff we've been
hearing about programs chris that are
only testing guys who are symptomatic
or are proven to have been in close
contact with someone who has covet 19.
so it looks like three out of the five
conferences intend to go forward and in
my view that's the worst outcome for the
nfl
i think from the nfl's perspective
they're not saying anything other than
we are closely monitoring the situation
you don't want two college football
seasons
do it all in the fall do it all in the
spring don't do one in the fall one in
the spring because then you can't take
over saturdays
in the fall if you want to move games
from sunday to saturday for tv purposes
and you're still stuck with the idea
this is this problem what the hell do we
do with the draft yeah because there's
still going to be college football
happening in the spring no it's going to
make life insane for nfl evaluators and
scouts and gm's and everything like that
you're right
there's no doubt about that so i'm not
surprised the big 12 was playing
football i expected them to join the
ranks of the sec
and and acc i did you know we just heard
jerry jones he's down there in dallas
texas he wants fans in the stadium
you know people are going to be behind
that i know that longhorn fans they're
they're sitting there going damn we're
austin texas we're all about longhorn
football
so you know that they're they're going
to push that message same thing with
oklahoma boomer sooner i mean
they live that so it's a huge part of
their culture i did not think they would
go down
you know easily i thought they would
fight this because
it is you know it's the south and that
part of the country football
is you know right there with religion
and marriage as they always say so
it's it's an important part i just hope
again just like we've talked about can
they do it safely
can they make sure it doesn't spread
through communities and it's on them
to do this and they're going to take the
the financial liability risk whatever it
may be
and we'll see where it goes somebody
other than bob bolesby will be the
commissioner of the big 12 when they
finally clean up the last of the covet
19 lawsuits that
inevitably will be filed by players
family members coaches etc
if they go forward without the right
level of
care and the right level of testing and
evaluation
and quarantine and all that stuff so hey
look maybe they'll pull it off
but uh the fact that the big 10 and the
pac-12 have both decided it's not safe
to proceed
that's exhibit a in the lawsuit against
any of the schools from the big 12 the
sec or the acc the two major conferences
said
mike we just can't do it but but you
guys go ahead and do it we don't think
it's safe but go ahead go ahead and do
the thing that we don't think is safe no
i i know you're right i mean it's it's
it's crazy i don't know we're living in
a crazy world right now and then and you
know messages are all over the place and
all that i'll tell you
the one thing to me that that i don't
think
is being talked about as far as being
the biggest factor
into if college football wants to work
and everything like that listen i i
believe in a lot of what like what nick
saban
said you know i'm not saying you know
where he just goes hey you know what we
here have here at football we can
provide one of the more safer
environments you can find out there yeah
i can get behind that i get that but to
me if college football is gonna work too
mike
all right you know the big thing is
are there gonna be students on campus
what are some of these schools doing
about that
because you know i would feel very
confident texas i went there i know how
it's set up they could set up their own
bubble for the football team and
everybody be okay
they stay in jester dorm it's a walkway
away from the stadium
but if there's fans i mean kids at
school and all that mike
you know that would scare me about it
going forward really scare me because
then i don't trust the kids on the
football team to be disciplined to be
able to go through and stay in the
bubble and all that
but here's the problem if it's not safe
for the student body i know
safe for the players and how do you have
college football without college that
that's why i thought early on the wheels
were going to come off of this
experiment right before it even gets
going
because you can't because what happens
is in your zeal to get the college
football season in and grab that money
from the networks you are going to
expose
the reality these guys aren't student
athletes they're athletes
they're unpaid labor and we're going to
bring them in and we're going to put
them in a dorm and we're going to shut
them off from society
so they're healthy enough to go out and
play in the football games and make us
our money
and if students aren't there it becomes
more gla
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports